after I told you sir put the sounds down
a Washington DC man is taken into
custody after allegedly stealing a
pre-packaged sandwich from Target after
refusing to leave the store when it
closed sir relax
the sandwich
es
just before 9 30 pm on June 20th a
Target employee flagged down an off-duty
Washington DC metropolitan police
officer the employee reported a man
inside the store who refused to leave
when the off-duty officer approached the
suspect he still wouldn't comply that's
when the officer called for backup
oh
male female
officers can be heard on body camera
video saying they believe the incident
to be mental health related is he giving
you a reason
foreign
video then shows the off-duty officer
approached the suspect saying he cannot
eat food he hasn't paid for
you understand what I told you earlier
[Applause]
the suspect is again told the store is
closed and that he needs to make his way
to the exit sir
so what I need you to do is start
working toward the front
take the bag off it's then that the
suspect is told he's under arrest for
stealing the sandwich
with that
yes you just stole the school you didn't
pay for it as First Responders attempt
to take the man into custody he takes a
bite of the sandwich after I told you
sir put the sounds down
even after this the suspect still
refuses to put down the sandwich
I really I don't want to do
you back
inside your back Sir
we don't want to fight you because
what's going to happen Okay put the
sandwich down put the sandwich down
sir relax
the sandwich please
sir do me a favor
let go of the sandwich
the man can then be heard voicing
concerned that his arm may get broken
almost
home
move your arm behind your back
okay
I got it sir
no okay
sir stop finishing up no I'm not gonna
break your arms body camera video shows
the struggle continue
follow directions
The Originals
sir Let It Go
officials then spray The Suspect with
pepper spray he was later taken to the
police department where he complains of
neck shoulder and wrist pain he was
taken to the hospital and later released
right now the incident is under review
by the United States attorney's office
for the District of Columbia once that
review is complete the Metropolitan
Police Department's Internal Affairs
Bureau will conduct a separate
investigation reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie